estoy convencido de que la banca como la
hemos conocido en los últimos 40 años
más o menos está por extinguirse
las innovaciones tecnológicas están
cambiando de manera dramática la forma
en que se gestionan los clientes y en
que se gestionan los riesgos y esa es la
esencia misma del negocio bancario eso
entraña retos
muy novedosos insospechados algunos para
los supervisores pero lo cierto es
que la era digital y los desarrollos
basados en la inteligencia artificial
obligan a las entidades a adaptarse a
estas nuevas circunstancias o de lo
contrario posiblemente a desaparecer en
el mediano plazo
de inteligencia artificial se viene
hablando desde la década de los
cincuentas
en el hombre parece haber una especie de
obsesión por desarrollar artefactos e
instrumentos capaces de replicar lo que
hace el ser humano pero obviamente con
mayor velocidad con mayor exactitud
mayor precisión con mejores resultados
con un menor margen de error recordemos
que la robótica está considerada una de
las ramas de la inteligencia artificial
por eso en la industria de la
manufactura encontramos muchos ejemplos
muy interesantes ya desde hace mucho
tiempo fábricas totalmente robotizada
que ensamblan y elaboran vehículos los
mismos procesadores que llevan las
computadoras en el interior
diagnósticos médicos más recientemente
ya hay robots que hacen suturas en los
en los seres humanos hasta llegar a las
impresoras 3d que mencionaba javier
capaces de imprimir puentes edificios
enteros imprimiendo cada uno de sus
componentes que luego se van ensamblando
pero el hombre siempre sueña con más
siempre quiere crear la máquina que
llegue a aprender por sí sola casi a
pensar igual que él y si pudiera
posiblemente crearía algún robot que
tenga sentimientos
por eso hablamos hoy
escuchamos hablar mucho hoy de lo que se
ha venido a llamar machine learning
máquinas capaces de aprender por sí
solas suena como algo así de los jets 11
en 1962 pero la realidad es que eso es
algo que ya está ocurriendo machine
learning es la conjunción de la
computación y la estadística para
preparar a las computadoras de manera
que corran algoritmos de manera
iterativa y además a partir de
interacciones con los seres humanos
vayan enriqueciéndose y seleccionando un
modelo cada vez más robusto un modelo
cada vez mejor ustedes seguramente
recuerdan hace algunos años cuando
llamábamos alguna empresa y nos atendía
una contestadora automática con una
respuesta totalmente plana si usted
quiere x marque 0 si usted quiere que
marque 1 si usted quiere z marque dos
hoy en día podemos casi dialogar con las
máquinas que nos atienden en los call
centers de muchas empresas nos hacen
preguntas diga su nombre
bueno el reconocimiento del aula del
reconocimiento lingüístico está
considerado también uno de los grandes
hitos de la inteligencia artificial y se
ha llegado al punto en que sus
algoritmos son capaces de determinar si
el cliente ya se está incomodando está
perdiendo la paciencia ya no quiere
seguir hablando al robot en cuyo caso lo
que hace
la máquina es que transfiere la llamada
a un operador humano para que termine la
relación con el cliente de manera que la
experiencia no sea tan difícil
la banca
entonces
es un campo tremendamente fértil para el
desarrollo de aplicaciones basadas en
inteligencia artificial por lo que decía
rebeca si alguien tiene información es
un banco o alguien puede tener llegar a
tener información es un banco piensen en
el emisor de la tarjeta de crédito o de
la tarjeta de débito que es con la que
ustedes cuentan el emisor de esa tarjeta
prácticamente vive en el bolsillo de su
pantalón dentro de su billetera es capaz
de percibir
en donde ustedes hacen sus compras cada
cuánto van al al molt qué tipo de comida
consumen a dónde les gusta vacacionar
imagínense la capacidad que tiene ese
emisor de las tarjetas de crédito para
determinar cuáles son sus gustos
preferencias tendencias que les atrae a
ustedes y ahora piensen en el impacto
que puede tener eso en el mercadeo
ahora quiero aclarar algo esto tiene un
impacto enorme en el mercadeo de las
entidades pero también en la gestión de
riesgos
hace unos años cuando no compraban por
internet algún producto simplemente
aparece el carrito se metía el producto
en el carrito y uno lo compraba y no
pasaba mucho más que eso
ahora la situación ha cambiado cuando
compran ustedes en internet algún
producto de inmediato empiezan a recibir
un mensaje mire las personas que
compraron ese producto también compraron
esto y también compraron esto otro o en
lugar de ese producto porque no compara
estos otros lo que hay detrás de esto es
un algoritmo
que está comparando los a ustedes
estudiando sus hábitos de consumo sus
inclinaciones sus gustos con los de
otras personas
para el algoritmo son similares a
ustedes y entonces aprovecha esa
información para tratar de incrementar
las ventas
bueno y qué hay de las redes sociales es
posible predecir patrones de
comportamiento a partir de el estudio de
las redes sociales la respuesta es
afirmativa ya hay algoritmos capaces de
analizar lo que se llama información no
estructurada que es la información que
se puede extraer de las redes sociales
imagínense ustedes esa información que
se extrae a partir del like que se da a
una foto a un comentario o de un
comentario que escriben ustedes en una
red como facebook o alguna de estas
bueno ya hay algoritmos capaces de
analizar ese tipo de información no es
no estructurada y derivar también
patrones de comportamiento a partir de
ese tipo de información
todo este tema de las grandes volúmenes
de datos que está causando esta enorme
disrupción típicamente se denomina
vistas y ya ha sido mencionado por
algunos algunos de los expositores
y justamente lo que se persigue es hacer
minería sobre toda esa big data
analizando información estructurada y no
estructurada para predecir el
comportamiento futuro de la gente
las implicaciones como les explicaba
antes no solamente están desde la óptica
del mercadeo sino que tienen mucho que
ver también con el tema de la gestión de
riesgos
por décadas los banqueros han tratado de
predecir el comportamiento de los
deudores sobre todo su voluntad de pago
muchas veces un deudor puede ofrecer
alguna buena garantía mostrar buenos
ingresos pero tener escasa o nula
voluntad de pago qué importante sería
entonces poder predecir de antemano cuál
cuál es lo que en gestión de riesgos se
denomina la probabilidad de
incumplimiento de cada uno de los
deudores
históricamente se ha hecho con base en
el pasado y entonces las naciones
reciben una probabilidad de cumplimiento
las empresas reciben un rating que son a
una probabilidad en cumplimiento y las
personas reciben un scoring
que anteriormente como dije eran
históricos pero ahora tienden a ser
prospectivos y como tienden a ser
prospectivos es decir proyectan cuál es
el escenario más probable de
comportamiento de esa persona bueno
porque comparan una gran cantidad de
variables que caracterizan a ese
individuo lo comparan con otros
individuos que el algoritmo determina
que son similares y entonces dicen este
individuo se me parece a este que ha
pagado bien y por lo tanto la
probabilidad de incumplimiento es muy
baja eso tiene un valor enorme
pero cuando empecé a trabajar en
desarrollos de estos algoritmos de estos
scoring vivimos algunas experiencias muy
interesantes
y recuerdo bien que la primera vez que
en el banco nacional en el cual estuve
los últimos 13 años desarrollamos el
primer scoring que pretendía ser
predictivo de cuál iba a ser la
probabilidad de incumplimiento
obviamente hubo algo de resistencia al
campo al cambio sobre todo saltaron dos
gallos
nosotros tenemos 20 años de experiencia
concediendo créditos ningún sistema que
usted ponga ahí va a superar
el feeling la experiencia el olfato que
hemos desarrollado nosotros a lo largo
de 20 años así que cuando el sporting
diga rechazado si a mí me parece yo a lo
aprueba el crédito
lo que decidimos fue hacer un trato vean
durante un año
yo voy a controlar la cartera aprobada
por ustedes con score in rechazado si al
final del año la morosidad de la cartera
que usted aprobó con square in rechazado
es relativamente alta entonces usted
abandona su olfato y le hace caso el
scoring un año después la mora de esa
cartera aprobada por ellos con el
scoring rechazado era cuatro veces la
morosidad de la cartera de consumo de la
oficina se acabó la discusión
realmente pueden extraerse
instrumentos muy valiosos a partir de la
aplicación de este tipo de instrumentos
no fueron pocos los retos que tuvimos
para empezar a trabajar en este tipo de
modelado que tiene mucho de aplicación
de inteligencia artificial sobre sobre
la sobre la beta está la primera
obviamente convencer al gerente general
de la época de hacer una gran inversión
en supercomputadores
qué era lo que necesitábamos para
procesar toda ese volumen de información
que un banco de ese tamaño relativamente
grande en costa rica puede puede tener
pero el reto más difícil sin la menor
duda fue encontrar a la gente
la universidad de costa rica
graduada en esa época tres matemáticos
por año
y yo les decía miren en realidad yo creo
que lo que gradúa en medio porque hay
dos y medio que lo que quieren es
estudiar unas cosas que yo no puedo
comprender de teoría de desarrollos
matemáticos y teoremas complejísimos y
aterrizados que quieran trabajar en un
banco medio por año eso es más o menos
lo que producen
y si todavía le pedimos al matemático
que sepa algo de programación que se ha
convertido en una necesidad
para tener verdaderos científicos de
datos les cuento que la cosa se pone
todavía mucho más complicada a mí me
parece paradójico que un país que atrae
la cantidad de inversión extranjera
directa que atrae costa rica porque
prepara muy buenos ingenieros muy buenos
técnicos prepare tan poquitos
matemáticos preparen muy pocos
econometristas y que además no les dé
esa formación integral
adicionando técnicas de estadística y
técnicas de programación que ese fue el
reto más grande que tuvimos pero además
la cosa se complica cuando ya están
totalmente preparados y listos porque
traten de retenerlos
la competencia de inmediato empieza a
tratar de llevárselos si no es que
renuncian y ponen su propia empresa de
venta de modelos a los otros bancos que
también viví esa esa experiencia
el resultado puede ser muy valioso muy
provechoso
y obtener todos estos temas de banca
digital cómo pueden ustedes ver en este
vídeo ofrecido por un banco español no
hay bancos costarricenses que han
avanzado mucho en el tema digital no
quise poner a ninguno de ellos para no
entrar en conflictos de intereses así
que lo que les traigo es este vídeo
preparado por un banco español en que
muestran cómo ya es posible tener
prácticamente todos los servicios
bancarios en la muñeca en el reloj que
tienen
y que portan y que portan ellos
22 retos importantísimos que se pueden
solucionar con inteligencia artificial
el primero hablábamos del endeudamiento
de los hogares me parece que gerardo
tocó el tema se habla de que la gente
está sobreendeudada en costa rica bueno
qué tal si tuviéramos un asistente de
inteligencia artificial capaz de decirle
a la persona mire ya sus ingresos están
siendo superados por sus gastos ya no
está aportando lo suficiente a su fondo
de pensión ya no está aportando lo
suficiente a su fondo de inversiones
usted debería de tomar medidas
otro tema importante banca de desarrollo
yo vi a ejecutivos del banco sentarse
cuatro horas con un micro pequeño
empresario a tratar de elaborar un flujo
proyectado de acá porque no tienen los
sistemas contables suficientes para
poder dárselos al banco y tomar entonces
el banco una decisión acertada existirá
un asistente de inteligencia artificial
capaz de resolver esos dilemas
la respuesta es sí javier mencionaba a
siri de apple o vix pink que es la de
samsung se llaman artificial
inteligentes asistentes bueno qué tal
uno desarrollado por un banco
les presento a erika
del bank of america que supongo que para
eso se llama así
erika es un asistente de inteligencia
artificial que vive dentro de la app del
bank of america
lo que me encantó de erika es que es un
extraordinario ejemplo de machine
learning porque interactúa con los
usuarios y cuando alguno de ellos la
sorprende con una pregunta que no tenía
programada que ya no esperaba se va al
soporte humano busca una respuesta y
cuando el cliente queda totalmente
satisfecho almacena la pregunta y la
respuesta por si se la vuelven a hacer
en el futuro en otras palabras aprende
de la interacción se enriquece a sí
misma se fortalece y queda mejor
preparada para seguir atendiendo
clientes en el futuro
como supervisor les puedo decir
lo primero que descubrí ahora que
regresé a la superintendencia es que
colombia es miembro del grupo supervisor
regional lo cual me dio la idea de
preguntarles qué estaban haciendo ellos
en el tema de supervisión de las fintech
sobre lo cual realmente no tengo idea no
tenía idea todavía y con lo que me
salieron fue con lo de los los sandbox
es que mencionado andalucía y lo primero
que me imaginé fue un gato haciendo las
grasas las gracias en la caja de arena
pero ya me explicaron luego que se
llaman areneros regulatorios y me parece
brutal la idea de decir se trata de
ambientes de prueba donde llegan los
bancos y la shf intec a la
superintendencia y en ese ambiente de
prueba demuestran que tienen la
ciberseguridad suficiente la protección
al consumidor suficiente y hasta que no
reciben la aprobación de la
superintendencia entonces no nos
permiten ponerlo en producción y
ofrecerlo a los clientes resulta que la
gente que está más interesada
en entrar a los areneros según me decían
los colombianos son las mismas fintech
porque una vez que pasan por ahí tienen
el sello de aprobación de la
superintendencia y eso le genera una
gran confianza a los usuarios cierro con
dos comentarios en mi opinión como les
decía al inicio o los bancos real
realmente se hacen digitales realmente
desarrollan sus propias tecnologías
syntek o se asocian con nacientes para
ofrecerlas yo creo que tienen sus días
contados y la segunda como supervisor lo
que les puedo decir es que jamás el
supervisor debe evitar la innovación
está muy bien preocuparse por la salud
de los consumidores está muy bien
preocuparse por que las innovaciones
sean favorables para quienes las
utilizan pero lo más importante es jamás
impedir esa innovación y más bien
contrario a eso aprovecharla en la
medida de lo posible para que la misma
supervisión sea más efectiva y más
eficiente muchas gracias